Growing up, nothing was more
magical, or mysterious than the act of sex.
You know, I used to think that if your nipples touched a guy's nipples you were insta-pregnant!
It was so confusing because there were so many different portrayals of sex, you know?
Like on the one hand, there were my mom's romance novels that I'd steal and read in secret.
He thrust his
And her lips parted and they made a sound!
Finger tips brushing!  Oh!
Dude!
This is so dirty.
Then on the other hand there was like the paired down biological scientific version
that you'd learn about in sex ed
All right class!  Genitals.  They go together.
But not without a condom!  Ok?
Now these puppies will to protect you from STDs
such as Gonorrhea, Chlamydia, Herpes.
There's quite a few more that I know, if you want--if you're interested--refer to your textbook ok?
You just slide it on the banana and uh, this is a Magnum size
So it actually fits quite perfectly.  So I guess this is a Magnum banana.
This is my lunch so I'm going to...
And of course there was the overexaggerated, kind of frightening version of sex
Porn.
*sex noises*
I can't suspend my disbelief.
She just met the guy!
Yea but he brought her pizza.
But if she ordered and is paying for the pizza, then I don't understand how she can interpret his actions as being romantic!
True.
*climax exclamations*
Woa.
So dear clueless 15 year old me, your first time...probably not going to be that great.
And it will hurt but it wont be that painful.  Or at least it shouldn't be.
And if it is, for some reason.  Stop!
Doctors and I, we can't recommend lube enough!
And don't be afraid to figure out what works for you!
If you need a toy to reach orgasm.  Don't be ashamed of getting one, go get that toy!
Always be safe.  Know your contraceptives.  Condoms, birth control, IUDs.
Whatever works for you.  Better safe than stuck with an STD you got from a liar
and or pregnant before you're ready to be a mom.
Also having sex isn't going to change your life.  I used to think this but
sex is kind of overhyped.  I mean don't get me wrong.  It feels amazing
but it's not going to completely change you as a person like you may think that it will.
Oh!  And always pee afterwards.  UTIs...they're not great.
And if you do get one, go see a doctor and guzzle some cranberry juice.
And finally, if a guy's boner isn't cooperating don't take it personally.
He's probably just as nervous as you are.
Alright, good luck.  Be safe.  And stay awesome Gotham.
*whistling*
Is that how it sounds?
*strong whistle*
Alright huddle up kids!
Squarespace has sponsored today's episode and I want to say thank you.
You can start going to Squarespace.com right now and build your website today.
All of the sites look professionally designed regardless of your skill level.
And all the tools are intuitive and easy to use, even an old man like me could do it.
When you go to checkout, Timmy, I want you to use the offer code "Anna"
For 10% off.
So start your free trial today.  No credit card required.
*bell ringing*
Squarespace.  *whistles*
Back to the balls!
People have this weird urge to comment on my race.
So, what exactly are you?
Uhm, well I'm Japanese, Hawaiian, Filipino
Woa, you are way too Asian.
English, German, Spanish, French, Irish.
Wow!  You are not Asian enough!